[Musique]
ambiance studieuse dans l'hémicycle du
département où étaient réunis les
parents et les enfants inscrits sur la
plateforme acadomia un site
d'accompagnement aux devoirs des enfants
qui a été financée par la sdr au
bénéfice des allocataires comme la
famille nous tiens franchement en tant
que parent on est dépassé par les leçons
et l'enseignement comme nous on a reçu
et maintenant c'est différent
donc le fait qu'on peut s'assurer on est
assuré d'avoir le les aides en ligne
mais déjà on n'a pas besoin de se
déplacer il suffit de se connecter
ben ça nous rassure de savoir que nos
enfants ils peuvent se débrouiller au
niveau des leçons un moment d'échangé a
été organisée avec ses enfants car
depuis 2019 ce sont eux les plus assidus
du travail scolaire une excellence à lui
par le bailleur social la sidr qui
logent des familles les plus
défavorisées a eu cette idée parce qu'à
la réunion vous savez il y à un
décrochage scolaire qui nous a
sensibilisés et une héroïne l'idée de
cette action qui est certes très
inhabituel de la part d'un bailleur
social en nous l'a dit mais qui
aujourd'hui montre la satisfaction des
locataires à quand tu as un taxi un mot
gentil bienveillant et plein d'espoir a
été donné à tous les enfants de la
sixième à la terminale ils pourront
ainsi utiliser de nouvelles tablettes
afin de garantir une continuité
pédagogique de la connexion internet
jusqu'aux équipements le département
accompagne ces jeunes au quotidien
l'école l'avenir de l'école et le
numérique
qu'on le veuille ou non donc il faut
accompagner les enfants nous c'est ce
qu'on fait avec les collages depuis la
connexion
jusque au visage mais pour qu'il y ait
des usages bas il faut des outils des
outils tout simple des tablettes ou des
ordinateurs
donc ce qui a été fait aujourd'hui ça
rentre dans ce cadre là dans cette
stratégie départementale une image de
fin qui illustre l'espoir transmis à
cette génération
car malgré ce contexte de crise
sanitaire ils vont devoir faire la
société demain
[Musique]